the Russian Foreign Minister is in Saudi
Arabia where he has just met with the
chief negotiator of the Syrian
opposition to discuss reconciliation
Sergey Lavrov expressed hope that the
opposition would help to facilitate the
return of refugees we appreciate your
commitment to finding solutions and we
expect that you and other
representatives of the Syrian opposition
will contribute to creating a
constitutional committee and of course
we expect that the responsible elements
of the Opposition support the provision
of assistance to Syrians by the
international community not only in the
form of humanitarian aid but also in
terms of water supply educational and
medical services and enabling refugees
and displaced people to return to their
homes with more on the meeting Eagers
done of reports from Saudi Arabia's
capital the Russian Foreign Minister has
just met with the members of the Syrian
opposition belonging to the so-called
political wing of the Syrian opposition
movement meaning that basically there
are not exactly members of any militant
group on the ground I should say it was
a surprise meeting really it wasn't
announced it wasn't anywhere in the
program in fact we journalists had
already boarded the plane expecting to
depart shortly so according to the
Russian Foreign Minister according to
Sergey Lavrov they found some common
ground as they talked about the
possibility of the elections in Syria
and as well as the new Syrian
Constitution this meeting is coming
right after the Russia's foreign
ministry's statement on the recent
report by the OPCW on last year's
chemical attack in Syria's Duma
now the Russian Foreign Ministry is
saying that they are studying this more
than a hundred pages long report very
carefully but the Russian Foreign
Ministry can already say that from what
they can see is that the UN bad body is
ignoring their information that certain
parts of the attack could be staged like
the video from a hospital that emerged
right after the attack this is something
that Russia had warned months in a
before that incident happened the vague
conclusions the OPCW body is making in
its report could be used to justify the
u.s. British and French aggression
against the Syrian government so this is
what the Russian ministry is talking
about when they're saying that well the
OPCW is somewhat ignoring Russia's
information that some parts of that
chemical attack were staged
you